so the Olympics are going on if you
heard about that in Sochi between the
gay hating and the dog killing and the
threat of terrorism Bob Costas is
pinkeye am I missing anything else thank
guys hey guys Johnny Weir completely
fabulous outfits I'm pretty sure he's
gay he's like gay gay real gay but I
thought this was interesting so who's
becca stan has announced that they are
going to use genetic testing to find
future Olympians develop countries
throughout the world like the US China
and European countries are researching
the human genome and have discovered
genes that define a propensity for
specific sports we want to use these
methods in order to help select our
future champions after the 50 genes of a
child are tested from a blood sample
their parents will be told what sports
they are best suited for and that's the
director of the genetics laboratory at
News Becca Stan's Institute of bio
organic chemistry I am glad we have a
legitimate scientist on the panel here
so my first question would be this has
got a little Nazism to it don't you
think like there's a little bit of
selection and I guess you could say that
this rings the bell of eugenics but I
don't think they're talking about
killing anybody I think they're talking
about selecting kids ahead of time to
here's the issue it's not gonna work
that's the real problem the problem
isn't so much why they're coming at it
this way because I don't think this is a
new idea I think this is something that
a lot of different countries have talked
about doing I'm sure there are labs here
where individuals are talking about
doing this and we do this with animals
all the time
that horse is made to the idea here is
that you're probably going to learn more
about somebody's athletic ability by
actually testing their athletic ability
then then testing them for genetic
propensity these people are ten years
old I mean they're they're old enough to
play sports right line them up have them
run a race take the ones who are running
the fastest and train them to be your
future Olympians it's very silly to try
and look at the genome because we aren't
there yet we don't know what this
specific gene does look we're not even
close we don't know what this specific
gene does we don't know how this gene
interacts with that gene and that gene
and that gene downstream we don't know
how this gene is turned on or off by
environmental factors it's silly it's
absolutely silly
I want to apologize to my who's Becky
fans purpose everything you're gonna say
with that apology you let some backwards
ass country like who's Becca Stan do
this yeah and they are dumbest posts and
corrupt and have a history of corruption
like you know that this ends poorly to
get to your first point like so we're
not there yet they're gonna find some
way that we're only going to get the
privileged kids who are related they're
gonna find some way to deny some this is
gonna end up costing them good athletes
because they won't recognize some good
athlete because they will force mate to
rediculous whose Becky's together who
they think are good at swimming and when
all they wanted to do was win the [ __ ]
out of whose Becca's which might be
landlocked apologize for that as well so
it's just like you could just you could
sense that this ends well like you want
to like you know what you should do
invest in a serious Olympic program and
build some stadiums and get kids there
and recruit them and run them like you
said and then see it and develop it and
spend some money but of course my
understanding is you probably spent some
money on the rest of your population
right and of course only rich people
arguing rich countries will be even if
it was legit let's say we could fig
that and figure it out only rich
countries were able to do this and they
were gonna have to separate Olympics one
for the regular people and then one for
the genetically-modified is one of the
great democracies of Europe now I I'm
gonna regret the same okay I mean it's
like even getting past all of the
sociological implications and all of all
of the you know inequality the income
inequality implications of this I've got
to reiterate it's not even going to work
and it's not about these people being
modified it's about trying to to blindly
look through their DNA and find some
sort of marker that says I'm going to be
good at a sport and we have found
genetic markers there's a marker that
was mentioned in the Atlantic article
that talks about this there's an author
of a book who who kind of lends his
expertise and heat
talks about how there is a genetic
marker that we know exists for
fast-twitch muscle fibers and the truth
of the matter is you're not going to win
100 meter sprint if you don't have this
this mutation if you don't carry this
gene but but also most people carry it
it's something like one in seven million
I don't remember the statistic but but a
very small portion of the population
doesn't have this so yes those people
will probably never be Olympians when it
comes to the Sprint but that's a very
small portion of the population right
it's just it and that's such a prime
example of when we take science and we
try to we take one very small example
one very small anecdotal example and we
try to apply it to every different usage
right that's just not how genetics work
people try to say oh you have the gene
for brown eyes or you have the gene for
blue eyes it's so much more complicated
and than that just to see what your eye
color is but we're used to
remembering Mendelian genetics in high
school you guys remember the punnett
squares yeah and the pea plants and this
one has this one is tall and this one is
short and this one has a wrinkly seed
and this one has a smooth seed and if
you crossbreed them this is what you get
but that's a single allele that's got
simple dominance and none of your
genetics is that easy and that's
something that we have to really
remember something querido who's becca
stan - totally yeah by the way you you
remember in high school and then i
didn't understand one word out there in
the youtubes is drawing a punnett square
right for our movie guy here what this
was reminding me about was the movie
Gattaca right because that's basically
what they were doing they were doing it
and felt that it could actually work in
the movie but there so that's why I'm a
little torn by this because on one hand
I love the science idea I love the idea
that this could be done and we could
create this group of people that can do
better things than we can do but on the
other hand doesn't it like take away the
most human thing there is which is like
you're born and maybe you have a chance
to do something and like beat your
genetics you know like actually I think
that it's not going to ever take that
away I think that's the important
outcome of this is that there there may
be an attempt to take that away but
the truth is you cannot control your
that's the great thing about about
procreating the way that we do it's the
great thing about being human beings and
not cloning but mixing up our all of our
genes so you take two people who have a
certain genetic profile and you breed
them they still may have offspring
that's completely different because
you're not going to simply just get half
of moms and half of dads they're all
going to be shuffled around and it still
is a total crapshoot how they're going
to end up and I think that's the
beautiful thing about our type of sexual
reproduction and you've got to remember
that so and bring us home there's no way
it's great like there are ways that that
sports and science have come together in
really impressive ways in the last 10
years just in starting in baseball with
just the studying of better studying of
statistics that is now lending itself to
basketball where we can measure a
player's production based on every
minute he's on the court and now ways to
sort of include science and training and
so forth but there is no conceivable way
that is Becca Stan asked at the very end
what is the point is this all is it all
about like having big balls
is it really just a pride thing I mean
is there any sort of monetary incentive
here what the [ __ ] is the put why does
this matter or Steve a relatively new
country and and you know the Olympics
like they matter a lot here but I think
for a lot of the world they matter even
more like it's a big deal this is their
chance this is you know because like I
sit here and make fun of Pakistan and
stand behind it but but I like politics
but like is Becca Stan doesn't get an
opportunity to stand toe-to-toe on the
world stage often and in the Olympics
everybody gets a chance to stand out so
if they win you know you remember how
much nonsensical pride those Eastern
Europe you were talking about it you
know a Germany and judges Avakian how
they mostly East Germany and and
obviously the Soviet Union when they
throw out these you know these
ridiculous athletes that were obviously
scientifically answers but right Drago
who fought rock
on Christmas Day in Moscow all right I
feel like that's a fitting end to that
well you know what actually to Cara's
point as Jeff Goldblum said in Jurassic
Park life finds away so this whole thing
is doomed to failure references in the
last two minutes I'm on it I'm on it
right now